Die Maschine ist sehr einfach zu montieren.
ich habe das heute ich habe das heute über fünf stunden gehört das lief die
ganze zeit im hintergrund heute so lange habe ich das noch nie durchgehalten
die taps wie sowas ist mit den taps funktioniert doch alles wunderbar
das gucken wir morgen wenn die videos von ihm immer ganz nice aber nicht heute
aber wir machen jetzt ein bisschen was anderes an
dein pc 6 1 halb jahre halt je nachdem was du machen willst ist es in der heutigen zeit
gar nicht so schlimm nee nee dann lieber das hier
ich mein hey immer noch besser leute immer noch besser als
immer noch besser das kennen die leute von heute wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr
ja das war das waren schon schon memes bevor es das wort gab ja besser besser 10 stunden
10 stunden es geht immer noch schlimmer ja das stimmt schon und mal lassen wir ein bisschen
machen 10 stunden das halte ich glaube nicht aus
aber in 10 stunden sekunde ja ja ja intensiv ist ein aus ach du scheiße 10 stunden
okay genug leute das kann ich mir nicht länger als ein paar minuten geben
danach kann sich einweisen lassen ja es gibt es gibt ganz viele solcher dinger
ja das stimmt das ist ja ungefähr das was ich vorher auch am start hatte ich hatte letzte mein
letzter pc war ein 8 war ein 8700 kam mit 1080 t und der hielt echt erstaunlich lang fünf jahre
ja nach drei jahren habe ich schon erzählt ich muss jetzt endlich mal neuen pc kaufen aber habe
ich nicht gemacht bis letzten bis letzten dezember letzten dezember habe ich dann habe ich dann eher
zugeschlagen ein habe ich einen wahren schnapper gemacht beim neuen pc übrigens ausrufezeichen pc
wer die teile sehen will und und sich das natürlich auch alles kaufen will über mein geist als reflink
wie viel pc ist wie viele rammen 64 geht glaube ich erstmal kurz gucken wo sieht man das jetzt
windows ja 64 g guck mal er weiß sogar wie viel slots auf mainboard gejust sind
könntest du zur nächsten season ein video machen ja mache ich wenn die nächste season kommt wann
ist denn diesen fünf release date gibt es da schon was das letzte mal ach ja es ist jetzt raus
ach weiß man das jetzt okay das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen und wenn es gab einen neuen
trailer von einem von einem tag oder wie den können wir uns gleich mal angucken warum nicht
season 5 gameplay da muss man wieder hier hackermann kram rausholen das funktioniert
so wir gucken wir gucken uns hier mal schnell an mal gucken ob es da irgendwas gescheites
gibt was man kurz reingucken ansonsten ich habe heute nichts großartig vorleute ich ich weiß wir
haben die letzten streams relativ wenig also wir haben uns ein bisschen die sharp features angeguckt
wir haben wirklich schon lange keinen richtig krassen hackermann scheiß mehr gemacht oder
irgendwelche microcontroller gebastelt oder sonst was ich krieg das nach der arbeit auch gerade
alles nicht nicht auf die reihe dann noch hier im five hat super five hat content zu machen ich
habe auch schon 14 tage kein video hochgeladen aber ich denke euch ist auch einen lieber als
wir lieber uns drei stunden hinsetzen ein bisschen schwätzen und ein bisschen links und rechts gucken
über aktuelle technik sachen reden anstatt gar nicht also trailer darf man aber battlefield schon
mal gar nichts drauf geben weil wenn eines eigentlich noch vor dem release gut war dann
war es der trailer zu dem spiel
okay soundtrack hat das spiel immer noch nicht
die beste passt mal auf guckt euch das mal an
die beste idee vor einem panzer also wenn ihr mal wenn ihr mal vor einem panzer weglauft leute
das ist das beste was ihr machen müsst erst mal eine runde auf der erde rollen direkt vorm panzer
ganz wichtig also man könnte alternative links oder rechts zur seite gehen aber nein nein leute
erst mal die 60 auf der erde rollen vorm panzer das ist wirklich mega infanterie mehr geht echt
nicht das spiel mittlerweile gute maps nee aber bessere als zum release teilweise
okay wir sehen eine neue schneemap
hat man da hat man da
ich dachte das ist eine battlefield 3 remake waffe
oder ist das eine battlefield remake waffe wir werden es gleich sehen
ist das ein g36
german weapons
dass die immer noch versuchen story in diesem game irgendwie aufzubauen das hatte von anfang
an keine und das was da war war total inkonsistent und atmosphäre ist auch nicht wirklich vorhanden
aber gut machst du noch ein video zu overwatch 2 pve also dass es gecancelt wurde
game hat mich nicht gejuckt obwohl ich auf aber was eins krass gegründet haben
okay skin skin skin skin skin ja okay und neue map auf jeden fall irgendwas mit schnee
neue battle pass ok war auch klar
premium skin
our class ja endlich also leute ohne miss our class war von anfang an so eine rotz map
vielleicht ist die jetzt halbwegs spielbar aber die du konntest ja schon gleich mal das
game liefen sobald our class ran kam das war glaube ich mit ich muss mir jetzt müssen wir
in mich gehen ob es wirklich die schlechteste battlefield map ist die ich hier gespielt habe
aber es ist auf jeden fall ganz oben mit dabei
und und und wisst ihr und wisst ihr was man jetzt was was richtig wisst ihr was jetzt richtig mega
wäre zum schluss bei so einem trailer ja wenn dieses spiel einen soundtrack hätte und man
könnte jetzt das battlefield team einspielen an der stelle also jetzt gut ich kann das nicht
machen aber ihr wisst was ich meine genau passend geschnitten dazu so nach dem motto jetzt fertig
das spiel hat halt kein soundtrack gibt nichts was es sein zu spielen gibt
da kann ich mich immer wieder drüber lustig machen aber man kann sich da eigentlich auch
gar nicht genug drüber lustig machen passt mal auf battlefield 2020 official official soundtrack
also erstens das spiel hat sagenhafte 42 minuten official soundtrack ist nicht so
dass es das ist jetzt ultra viel wäre 14 tracks aber aber der sound leute der sound
ich weiß was gehen wir gehen wir auf 39 22
ich meine dass das soll das battlefield team sein eben die waren in den letzten teilen schon immer
ein bisschen nicht so richtig wobei stimmt nicht stimmt nicht ich glaube battlefield 5 war es ich
glaube die hatten eine ganz gute war oder was battlefield 1 eine ganz gute variant davon aber
die waren schon die letzten sachen nicht nicht so geil battlefield 1 hat einen richtig guten
soundtrack aber ich meine hört euch das mal an das kann doch nicht sein oder was was ist das
ist das kabel nicht richtig eingesteckt oder was
wollt ihr mich veräppeln das ist doch kein battlefield themen
das ist das ist keine ahnung irgendwas rückwärts abgespielt oder so und dabei
hat battlefield 1 richtig gute richtig gute musik zum beispiel den dem in dass das allein
schon das menü themen war mega mega park genau hört sich an wie wenn der audio treiber fehlt
oder wenn man die falschen soundsettings hat aber das allein schon das menü themen battlefield
1 war der battlefield 1 sehr wenig gespielt aber der der soundtrack war gut
wir haben versucht auf linux zu mixen genau
das war das war richtig guter soundtrack
wird noch besser
das ist wirklich mega soundtrack badabu dings dankeschön für den zap ja ist da ist der plan
wir gucken uns ein paar stellen anzeigen an weil ich brauche unbedingt welche damit ich
mal wieder ein video machen kann dazu wird wird echt mal zeit
das ist schon absicht gehe ich mal davon aus dass es daran erinnert oder zumindest von von
der inspiration her aber ich ich muss ja immer noch sagen dass das kann jetzt sein dass es so
ein bisschen bisschen so nostalgie aus meiner anfangs youtube zeit ist was ich was ich aber
immer noch als als mega leisten soundtrack empfinde ist mw2
okay das ist nicht das weg das ist das da
das ist hans zimmer ich weiß ich glaube es war auch das einzige einzig was dafür
call of duty gemacht hat also was heißt der das studio der persönlich da was gemacht hat
kein plan getrunken habe ich gerade schon aber das ist halt vielleicht ein bisschen so zur
nostalgie aus der zeit von 2011 also 2009 kam es glaube ich raus war das 1911 so
na das war schon das war schon äußerst ja ja gibt noch mehr als der mw2 soundtrack
finde ich ist auch immer noch der beste call of duty soundtrack den sie bisher hatten
das ist legit nur ein werbevideo gewesen für den battle pass ja im prinzip schon aber es gibt
immerhin neue map anscheinend paar als man hatte schon paar battlefield 3 waffen beziehungsweise
battlefield 4 waffen gesehen ja also dass kein neuer specialist wobei ich gar nicht weiß ob es
neues specialist kommt wahrscheinlich nicht aber ist ja auch egal also wäre es nicht schlimm ich
brauche nicht noch mehr specialist also wie das spiel hat hat mittlerweile keine guten maps die
einzigen guten maps die sie haben haben sind alte maps beziehungsweise die neuen über neuen maps
überarbeitet sind teilweise auch ganz ganz okay mittlerweile schon mitbekommen dass windows
bald 7zip und so weiter native anpacken kann wenn du knapp unter 2000 euro hättest für
einen pc würdest du gerade eher in am 4 oder 5 investieren ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich habe
keinen durchblick was desktop pcs angeht und gerade was amd angeht auch nicht ich habe genau
zu einem zeitpunkt durchblick wenn ich mir wenn es um desktop pcs geht und das ist der zeitpunkt
wo ich mir neuen pc kaufe und nachdem es jetzt schon wieder ein halbes jahr her ist wo ich mir
den neuen pc gekauft habe also übrigens hier die zusammenstellung was kostet der jetzt aktuell was
alter was für ein krasser preisverfall oder ach moment da fehlt da ok ok da fehlt was da fehlt
was da fehlt der preis für das netzteil und ja aber trotzdem ist er ja gut sagen wir 1000 euro
preisverfall nur die grafikkarte die grafikkarte kostet halt einfach 500 euro weniger schon mal
cpu ist auch ein bisschen billiger preisentwicklung
es liebte
ja hier habe ich es kommt mal hier so in dem ich habe es ich habe es ungefähr so in dem
dreh hier glaube ich gekauft so irgendwie so knapp um 5000 euro und ist aber gut ich meine
hardware hat erst mal preisverfall es fakt das ist ja das ist ja normal es ist ja immer so also
wenn die sachen rauskommen ist immer teurer und wird dann über das nächste jahr über das ja
normal aber das schon heftig oder monate später einfach mal über 1000 euro weniger gut das stimmt
nicht ganz da fehlt das netzteil zwischendurch es gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr aber warum nicht
ja also zu dieser frage ich kann ich kann die musik ist auch viel zu kommen wir machen
einen von unseren standard standard playlists wieder an das was wir immer
anhaben da ist wegen ein bisschen gedudelt im hintergrund jawohl
ups
wollte ich jetzt gar nicht wollte den browser aufmachen also das kann ich dir nicht wirklich
sagen ob einem vier oder einem fünf ich habe da zu wenig durchblick eine sache kann ich vielleicht
kann ich aber vielleicht dazu sagen es macht nicht immer sinn sich die neuste plattform zu kaufen man
muss sich das natürlich preisleistungsmäßig angucken ich habe keine ahnung ob 2000 euro
wofür das eher spricht ob schon neuestes oder ein bisschen älteres also es kann durchaus sein
dass man mit der generation davor preisleistungsmäßig viel viel besser fährt weil man nicht so viel
langsamer ist als das allerneueste aber halt viel billiger weil wenn man irgendwas bekommt was sagen
wir mal nur 15 prozent langsamer ist aber 50 prozent davon kostet dann macht das sinn und
2000 euro ist jetzt ja auch kein mega übertriebener preis für ein gaming pc das ist schon ein bisschen
auf der budgetseite kann man nicht sagen budget pc 5 600 600 700 euro vielleicht aber das ist ja
schon ein bisschen so im mittel obere mittelklasse range so pc den man für den preis kriegt also das
ist jetzt nicht super high end aber das ist eigentlich auch die preiskategorie wo man
meistens preisleistungsmäßig am besten rauskommt wenn man ordentlich power braucht ja also macht
durchaus sinn sich das anzugucken und ist also ich würde nicht automatisch am 5 nehmen am 4 nehmen
oder am 5 nehmen nur weil am 4 die ältere plattform ist wenn sich das preisleistungsmäßig
lohnt kann das kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein aber ich weiß es nicht ob das so ist
ne das habe ich nicht mitbekommen aber finde ich gut dann braucht man keine keine packprogramme
mehr wobei ich wahrscheinlich 7zip oder was habe ich hier gerade aktuell drauf prezip
noch ein bisschen mehr machen kann und ja windows das windows compress decompress
ist halt das kleinste gemeinsame nenner ich gehe mal davon aus die werden gar nicht alle
features unterstützen weiß gar nicht wie es mit encrypted 7zip archiven aussieht und so was keine
ahnung ob das was steckt ihr in eure rechner das 2k richtung mittelklasse geht naja also
wie würdest du es denn sonst bezeichnen wenn du rechner kategorie also wenn du dir die kategorie
anguckst dass du mit den dingen halbwegs spielen kannst so mein hat 5000 euro gekostet so wenn man
bei hardware rat guckt so einen so einen einstiegs halbwegs budget gaming pc kriegst für 500 euro
wie würdest du denn 2000 euro da nennen das ist doch ziemlich genau in der mitte und auch von der
von der power her ist das ziemlich gut aber nicht wirklich high end also wie würdest du es denn
sonst außer mittelklasse nennen oder sagen wir gehobene ich habe es ja gehobene mittelklasse
genannt wie willst du sonst nennen denkst du das neue bungee game könnte was für dich werden ich
weiß aus dem kopf gar nicht was das ich habe es gesehen noch gar nicht lang her vor drei vier
tagen oder so irgendwann es war das war das marathon marathon ist was anderes oder bungee
doch marathon genau ja
das ist doch irgendwann das genau das habe ich da habe ich ein artikel drüber gelesen dass das
irgendein remake ist von irgendeinem uralt game was sie für apple pcs rausgebracht haben
allerdings wo es bei mir schon ein bisschen aufgehört hat ist dass ich gelesen habe korrigiert
mich wenn ich falsch liege ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich die news im kopf gerade richtig
zusammenbringe dass es so ein extraction extraction shooter werden soll extraction
shooter ist so das neue battle royale also jetzt nachdem sich jetzt alle an battle royale
abreagiert haben machen jetzt alle extraction shooter
wie ist denn die neue arbeit da kann ich ein bisschen was zu erzählen insgesamt ist die
neue arbeit immer noch pock ich denke also ich hoffe mal dass wir nächster zeit noch so bleiben
die verwirrung ist in vielen bereichen schon weg allerdings so die die die großen zusammenhänge
so habe ich noch nicht ja also was die technik angeht funktioniert das alles wunderbar also wenn
mir einer sagt hier guckt mal irgendwie container image kann ich gepult werden oder sowas da gucken
woran es liegt und das irgendwie fix ist kein ding was was in dem laden wo ich halt arbeite
ein bisschen problematisch ist da ist da ist gott und die welt daran beteiligt für einfachste
sachen und da blicke ich noch nicht durch die fragen sich immer warum sie so langsam sind ganz
ehrlich ich kann ihnen sagen warum sie zu langsam sind warum sie so langsam mit allem sind weil sie
einfach übertrieben bürokratisch sind bei allem klar liegt bestimmt auch ein bisschen an finanz
und aufsicht und allem also übertrieben bürokratisch und drücken sich halt so dieses
agil label drauf in projekten so nach dem motto wir sind agil aber das einzige wirklich richtig
agil ist dass man einmal am tag ein daily scrum macht so und und und jira als ticketsystem
verwendet aber soll mir recht sein ganz ehrlich die müssen wissen wie sie das wie sie das machen
wollen und wenn das für sie unterm strich am besten ist was heißt für sie am besten für
für sie am einleuchtesten ist soll mir das recht sein solange die pünktlich bezahlen mache ich
auch mache ich auch langsames agil soll mir alles recht sein ist okay
jira genau oder oder jara wie man eine arbeit gesagt hat jara wir hatten eben schon merkwürdige
leute also ich habe schon selber tibet it bereich merkwürdige leute letzten jahre über gesehen und
immer mal wieder welche die alles super cool und geil aussprechen mussten ich sage nur shit und
die skins kosten nichts
naja nee die skins wenn du wenn du bock hast den battle pass durchzukleiden kannst du was
die skins nix du brauchst halt den battle pass bis bis zum schluss wenn da irgendein skin drin
ist kannst natürlich auch per pay to win den battle pass anlocken glaube das geht ich habe
so nie ausprobiert aber ja wahrscheinlich das geht ja überall also ich muss sagen einen der
coolsten battlefield trailer fand ich immer noch ich weiß boomer mäßig aber kennt ihr noch den
den bett company 2 multiplayer trailer wo sie so rüber geschnitten haben
nee das meine ich nicht dass da meine ich
okay jetzt wird es kompliziert kann das ich habe kann das vlc
kann das sekunde vm starten das muss ich jetzt mal schnell ausprobieren ob ich das
irgendwie was jetzt was jetzt los mit meiner vm was vm stream ach das ist wieder der scheiß
vm stream log file entfernen ja also wenn ihr mal das problem hat mit euren vm dass
er irgendwie der meinung ist er möchte nicht starten log files entfernen dann geht es wieder
warum vor allem am workstation diesen bug noch nicht nach jahren in griff gekriegt hat ist mir
schleierhaft wir müssen mal kurz was ausprobieren also das abspielen das abspielen geht ja nicht
warum auch immer das age restricted ist früher als das rausgekommen ist war das auch noch nicht
aber okay wer weiß youtube pegas network ich gehe den chat gleich durch ich will mal gucken ob ich
das mit youtube dlp runtergeladen krieg habe ich das ja achso wir sind ja der linux 0 habe ich doch
ok das geht anscheinend 720 plus audio hat keine ahnung 150
ach das geht zu downloaden jetzt ok nice
dankeschön für den ein vlc was das
ok das funktioniert
jetzt habe ich ja hier kein sound lol egal also wir müssen trailer wir müssen wir müssen trailer
nicht gucken ich will euch nur zeigen was ich an dem trailer richtig nice fand dass sie nämlich am
ende also sie haben ja gezeigt wie die wie das russen squad irgendwie erika aber einnimmt ja
und dann sieht man halt wie das so rausschwankt mit den mit den gamer tags oben drüber und
halt die anderen auch das fand ich das fand ich extrem nice gemacht
also ich finde immer noch dass das eines der besten trailer war einfach weil das richtig
bock auf die multiplayer gemacht hat und das nicht nicht nicht nicht so eine reine so eine
reine show geschichte war ich weiß war lustig war auch schau aber ich fand es fand es gut
erstmal wieder löschen
trinken erinnern mache ich
der macht die sachen ja nicht selbst das ist er hat ja sein komplettes studio also
also sei ein komplettes team dahinter wie viel er noch selbst komponiert keine ahnung
habe die tage ein bewerbungsgespräch für ausbildung zum fachinformatiker system integration
bereich linux ha wie kann ich das gut punkten bei der way personalerin ist etwas steif ja gut
das ist das ist normal aber man muss sich ein bisschen auf sein gegenüber einstellen also
wenn die streif und förmlich ist dann jeder vielleicht nicht rein mit all der leute was
geht ja sondern versuche ich war vielleicht ein bisschen an denen zu orientieren gut aber
vielleicht legt sich das vielleicht legt sich das ja auch wieder kommt auch kommt auch ein
bisschen ein bisschen auf die firma an aber dass einem als techniker personaler steil vorkommen
ist eigentlich ganz normal und du musst dich auch darauf einstellen dass sie dich komische
personaler fragen fragt also bei mir im vorstellungsgespräch also zum zum jetzt zum
jetzigen job wurde wurde ich so sachen gefragt wie welchen tipp würden sie ihrem könnten sie
ihrem oder wie ich weiß wie hat er das gesagt was wäre was wäre ein tipp den sie ihrem chef
geben könnten oder so was hat er gefragt oder was müssten wir machen um sie so richtig zu ärgern
und so komische fragen aber das ist ja hey das ist normal dass die personaler immer so ein bisschen
so trick trick reiche questions am start haben also die logik dahinter ist ja ist ja vielfältig
ja manche wollen fragen die leute absichtlich was unerwartet so nach dem motto wie reagieren
die leute denn manche erhoffen sich wirklich anhand der antworten irgendwie einblick da über
die personen zu bekommen da muss ich halt sagen ich glaube wenn das personale aus dem
grund versucht da sind sie relativ lost im vorstellungsgespräch sagt niemand was er
wirklich denkt sondern das wovon er denkt dass es gut ankommt und allein schon da sind ja ist
da ist die herangehensweise immer ein bisschen verkehrt so nach dem motto wir stellen dem jetzt
eine frage so wie würden sie in dieser wie würden sie in der und der situation reagieren so das
problem ist dass du gar nicht so in der situation reagieren würdest und das auch weißt aber du
sagst halt nicht wie du reagiert sondern du sagst wie du denkst dass die hören wollen dass
du reagiert also dementsprechend ist ja schon komplett unrealistisch da was über die leute
raus raus zu bekommen und wenn du falsch gedacht hast dann aber zumindest da musst du dir noch
keine gar nicht viel gedanken darüber machen wenn du als azubi da das gespräch hast da sind
sie ja wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so ganz so abgedreht drauf ja wie du punkten kannst also
der erste punkt ist tatsächlich wenn du zumindest ein bisschen ahnung über die firma hast wo du
hingehst wäre schon mal nicht verkehrt natürlich kannst du auch wenn du im bereich linux und
hochverfügbarkeit gehst also kannst du den erst mal nebenbei einstreuen dass du weißt du für ha steht
dass es steht für hochverfügbarkeit das kannst ja das würde ich jetzt nicht so direkt sagen ich
würde nicht sagen ach ja übrigens ich weiß auch dass er für hochverfügbarkeit steht sondern das
kann man ja so nebenbei in so einen nebensatz einbauen so nach dem motto ja ich beschäftige
mich jetzt auch schon eine ganze weile mit linux auch was auch was hochverfügbarkeit angeht deswegen
passt das ja mit mit ha einer stelle bezahlt irgendwie sowas ja denke ich was kannst du
irgendwas im nebensatz einbauen also das ist ja nicht verkehrt wenn ich ein bisschen über die
firma informiert wenn du dir überlegst wie du denen am besten das näher bringen kannst dass
schon ein bisschen linux erfahrung hast wenn du schon linux erfahrung hast ich meine du musst
jetzt auch nichts ausdenken hast du hast du schon linux erfahrung ambulanz wenn nicht ist das auch
nicht so schlimm dann solltest du aber hervorheben dass du eben an technischen themen interessiert
bist und dass linux auch was ist was dich interessiert und solche geschichten also man also
ich würde von einem azubi nicht warten dass er von anfang an super krasse ahnung hat bisschen
vorkenntnis im linux bereich ist schon ganz nice oder zwar ein bisschen bisschen vorkenntnis im
it bereich sind schon ganz nice muss jetzt auch nix linux spezifisches sein aber wichtig ist dass
die leute sich dafür interessieren ja das sollte das sollte unterm strich schon so rüberkommen
dass du zumindest interessiert bist im it bereich und ein bisschen ahnung von der firma was die so
macht ist auch nicht verkehrt ansonsten ja kommt ein bisschen auf die stellen anzeige an was die
da noch so geschrieben haben ansonsten so schwer ins blaue was zu sagen
subscription ja das finde ich auch also nicht verkehrt mal nachzugucken was macht die firma
eigentlich das ist das ist tatsächlich immer sinnig du musst jetzt nicht im detail wissen wie
der börsenkurs aussieht oder sowas aber zumindest was sie was was sie macht so grob und falls man
vielleicht auf denen ihre webseite schon was rauskriegt was sie denn an technologien benutzen
ich meine viele gerade jetzt nicht so super große läden schreiben ja auch schon ein bisschen was
auf ihrer homepage wir haben es jetzt schon öfters hier im stream gesehen dass die groß rum
fabuliert haben hier unser tech stack und solche geschichten und dann ist es natürlich nicht
verkehrt wenn die wirklich sowas auf der webseite stehen haben dass du dir mal anguckst okay was
benutzen die eigentlich und mal so die so die top fünf dinger daraus googles dass du zumindest
so grob weißt was das ist das macht einfach eindruck wenn jetzt einer sagt wir benutzen
hier bla bla bla bla zu monitoring und du kannst sagen ach ja ist das nicht dieses system für
langzeitmetrik archivierung oder sowas ist bei so ein beispiel dafür das finden die sicherlich
nice wenn du das weißt dann sehen die okay der hat sich schon ein bisschen damit beschäftigt
aber wie gesagt also große vorkenntnisse sind als azubi gar nicht nur zumindest für mich wäre das
nicht der ausschlaggebende punkt natürlich nice to have und und unterstreicht noch mal dass man
sich halt auch dafür interessiert das ist das wichtigste als azubi ganz ehrlich da muss ich
dafür muss ich für den kram interessieren das reicht eigentlich in der regel was hältst du
von job ausschreibungen die einen systemadministrator für die ganze firma suchen man wäre allein 50 50
mitarbeiter verantwortlich sowie alles drumherum ja du bist turnschuhadmin dann du darfst in
keller rennen oder ins rechenzentrum rennen zum drucker reparieren rennen zum tintenpatronen
wechseln rennen zum netzwerkkabel beim chef einstecken zur usv anschließen also ich hatte
keinen bock sowas zu machen das ist das also ich persönlich würde vermuten ich war nämlich kenne
die stellenanzeige jetzt nicht ich würde vermuten dass das ein recht undankbarer job ist mit sehr
viel stress und nervigen leuten die es nicht anerkennen was man da macht und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht mal gut bezahlt kommt natürlich immer ein bisschen darauf an wie groß wirklich am ende
dein aufgabengebiet ist also was die was die genau von einem wollen da muss man sich die
stellenanzeige zu angucken aber eher weniger leute habe ich euch schon erzählt ich hatte
letzte woche was letzte diese woche diese woche hat ich einen ich muss überlegen wie ich das wie
ich das jetzt umschreibe so eine eine einführungsveranstaltung trifft am besten
einführungsveranstaltung für neue oder vorstellungsveranstaltung für neue
mitarbeiter das war ein kompletter tag der termin durchgängig on board ja sowas in der
richtung könnte man es vielleicht nennen das war ein kompletter ein kompletter tag von morgens neun
bis 15 uhr 30 also quasi sechseinhalb stunden und naja
das war so zum größten teil so eine socialize veranstaltung ihr wisst ja wie
sehr ich bock auf sowas habe also das meiste dass okay das zum größten teil ging es zum
größten teil war das okay guck mal hier hier gibt es ein paar benefits in der firma guckt
mal hier wir haben übrigens auch jemand der sich da und darum kümmert und da haben irgendwelche
leute vorträge gehalten das war ganz okay aber zwischendurch kam halt immer dieses gezwungenen
socializing und das geht mir halt ultra auf den sack so dieses ja und jetzt ist eine super
gelegenheit zum nett wirken redet doch mal fünf minuten mit eurem nachbar ich meine hallo wenn
einer zu einem sagen muss redet doch mal fünf minuten mit eurem sitznachbar wenn ihr pause
macht von der viertelstunde dann rede ich mit meinem sitznachbar oder mit dem anderen
sitznachbar oder mit dem typ vor mir in der reihe oder oder wenn ich keinen bock drauf
habe dann halt mit gar keinem aber an sich war die veranstaltung gar nicht schlecht gemacht also
man muss sagen die haben sich die haben sich die haben sich schon mühe gegeben aber das war so
dieses gezwungenes socializen das war wieder echt so ein bisschen sehr sehr kritisch ja also da also
es gab so diese sachen mit ja so unterhaltet euch doch mal fünf minuten mit eurem sitznachbar was
was bei mir kein problem war ich habe mit dem sitznachbar geredet ja weil ich war mit
meinem kollege da den ich schon seit zehn jahren kenne ich habe doch von der alten arbeit jemand
mitgebracht auf die neue arbeit und wir waren natürlich zusammen weil wir haben gleich tag
zusammen hatten dort angefangen also waren wir auch beim bei der einführungsveranstaltung da
natürlich habe ich zehn minuten oder fünf mit meinem sitznachbar geredet
und dann ging es halt dann ging es halt weiter ach ja ich habe übrigens oder besser gesagt wir
wir waren wir waren ja zu zweit da wir haben die wir haben die schultaktik angewandt weil
jemand gerade geschrieben hat wie in der schule wir haben wir haben eine taktik aus der schule
angewandt die auch im echten also im berufsleben noch funktioniert und zwar vielleicht kennt ihr
das noch es ist irgendeine stunde auf die ihr gar keinen bock habt mit irgendeinem lehrer den ihr
nicht mögt vielleicht auch ein lehrer der irgendwie so ein bisschen strenger drauf ist vor dem ihr ein
bisschen schiss habt oder so und es ist auch ein thema wovon ihr überhaupt keine ahnung habt so und
in der schule hat man dann zumindest ich habe immer ganz gern die taktik gemacht wenn ich wusste
dass der lehrer jetzt quasi eine mündliche beteiligung von jedem im unterricht haben möchte
habe ich immer absichtlich dummes zeug gefragt wo ich die antwort eigentlich schon wusste damit
er im kopf hatte ada max der hat die stunde schon was gesagt ja zum beispiel was weiß ich
irgendwie physik ja und die haben dann irgendwas erzählt von weg und kraft und sonst was habe ich
halt irgendwas blöd also wenn ich dann gesehen habe der lehrer der will jetzt jeden mal dran
nehmen da habe ich mich dann habe ich mich gleich gemeldet ja sofort gemeldet weil ich keinen bock
hatte gefragt zu werden vielleicht zum thema wo ich keine ahnung habe ich immer sofort gemeldet
ich hätte noch mal eine frage wie ist das jetzt eigentlich so mit mit reibung bei der bei der
straße und so und wie rechnet man das ein und so habe ich was gefragt denn irgendwas was ich wusste
der lehrer hat an dem kopf abgespeichert max hat schon was gesagt so ich weiß nicht ob man mir
folgen konnte aber ich könnte mir vorstellen wie so eine taktik oder so ähnliche taktik hat jeder
in der schule angewandt um nicht auf dem falschen fuß erwischt zu werden mit fragen von denen keine
ahnung hatte so und das war auf der veranstaltung ganz genauso es gab erst zu dieses redet mal fünf
minuten mit euren kollegen dann war noch jemand da der wissen wollte wie war denn euer erster tag
und dann wurden dann auch wieder so random leute da im ganzen publikum gefragt hat ungefähr 100
leute da würde ich sagen in der veranstaltung und oder und dann haben sie gefragt ja und wie
seid ihr denn hier wie seid ihr denn zur firma gekommen und auch wieder leute gefragt also
erstens haben sie natürlich gesagt die leute können sich freiwillig melden aber hätte sich
keiner freiwillig gemeldet wisst ihr genau was passiert wäre oder was passiert immer wenn so
wenn die sache kommt und wer hat wer hat eine schöne geschichte zu erzählen über euren über
ihren ersten arbeitstag ja wer möchte dann was passiert wenn sich keiner was passiert wenn sich
keiner freiwillig meldet was passiert dass das erste was passiert ist es wird gesagt wie wäre
es denn mit ihnen daher in der zweiten reihe wollen sie nicht was dazu sagen sowas in der
richtung so und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht okay wir machen das jetzt einfach frei fährt
wir melden uns freiwillig und als sie gefragt haben wie sind sie denn zur firma gekommen haben
wir uns hingestellt haben uns gemeldet und haben gesagt zwei auf einmal gleich richtig gefreut ja
das ist absicht weil wir haben auch zusammen hier angefangen am gleichen tag und wir kommen vom
gleichen ex arbeitgeber und da habe ich im prinzip dort die story erzählt von unserer bewerbung die
ich auch schon fünf mal erzählt habe so dass ich quasi mich dort dass mich jemand angeworben hat
ich mich dann dort war zum vorstellungsgespräch und quasi die bewerbungsunterlagen für meinen
kolleg dabei hatte und abgegeben habe und dann hat alles funktioniert also ich habe quasi die
ganze story einfach noch mal erzählt vor 100 leuten also sogar mikrofon in die hand gedrückt für
so riesig war der raum nicht die hätten mich auch so gehört aber gut haben sie mir noch ein
mikrofon in die hand gedrückt dann habe ich dann irgendwie paar minuten die story erzählt
mein kolleg noch was erzählt und am ende habe ich da mal hingeguckt wir haben insgesamt viertel
stunde haben die haben wir erzählt und die haben uns dinger gefragt und sowas ging richtig schnell
rum aber das gute war nachdem wir einmal freiwillig uns gemeldet haben und was erzählt haben bei keiner
anderen sache wurden wir mehr gefragt zu nichts wurden wir mehr gefragt weil die hatten uns beide
schon im kopf ach das sind die zwei neuen it leute die heute in die viertelstunde lustige story
erzählt haben da hatten wir unsere ruhe es wurde den ganzen tag wurde uns nichts mehr gefragt auch
nicht mehr so und dann gab es später noch so komische so komische socialize spiele na spiele
ist das falschwort so socialize die andere anregungen wie man besser socializen networken
kann so nach dem motto setzt euch doch mal mit fünf leuten zusammen und überlegt euch was für
euer highlight der woche da kann ich nicht wirklich ehrlich sein wenn es was wenn es was
ist was nicht ganz arbeitskorrekt ist ja stell euch mal vor irgendeiner hatte verstopfung und
hat seit drei tagen wieder mal gekackt und das war sein highlight der woche der kann sich der
kann sich ja nicht hinstellen heute morgen endlich mal geschissen also die meisten leute
haben dann halt so belangloses zeug erzählt heute diese woche habe ich ja auch erst angefangen mein
erster arbeitstag war so schön die veranstaltung heute war so dass was so das highlight ja und
uns und solche geschichten und ein bisschen was ich mir überlegt habe in dem fall der fälle dass
sie mich gefragt also ich habe diese fünf minuten seriously kein witz ich habe diese fünf minuten
nicht genutzt um socialize sondern ich bin aufs klo gegangen und bin mal pinkeln gegangen und in
den fünf minuten wo ich auf dem klo gehockt habe habe ich mir überlegt okay was überlege ich jetzt
falls sie mich fragen sollte als antwort und ich bin zum schluss gekommen meine antwort ist wenn
die mich gefragt hätte meine antwort wäre gewesen mein persönliches highlight ist dass die bahn heute
pünktlich gekommen ist was auch tatsächlich ein highlight gewesen wäre das hätte ich dann
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen besser verkauft so nach dem motto ja ich weiß kann vielleicht
nicht mithalten mit dem was die anderen erzählt haben aber mein persönliches highlight dass die
bahn mal wirklich pünktlich ist ich meine strecke ist schon nicht sonderlich kompliziert muss gar
nicht umsteigen könnte ich noch ein bisschen erzählen dass ich gegenüber schräg da irgendwie
nicht weit vom bahnhof wohne und bla bla bla fünf minuten erzählung aber ich wurde nicht mehr gefragt
weil taktik nummer eins gegriffen hat wir haben gleich am anfang 15 minuten was erzählt und
wurden den restlichen tag nicht mehr belästigt eigentlich eigentlich eine gute taktik ja das
kann auch sein dass sie sich das gedacht haben aber wir haben nicht eine viertel stunde gelabert
wir wurden wir haben wir haben wir haben was erzählt und wir wurden dann immer noch
sachen gefragt deswegen haben wir eine viertel stunde gelabert
es gab natürlich auch wieder die super krassen selbstdarsteller auf dieser veranstaltung wie
soll ich das am besten wie soll ich das am besten beschreiben es war einer vom vorstand
da irgendwie so kurz um die neuen mitarbeiter zu begrüßen in der firma also er hat ein bisschen
ein bisschen eine viertel stunde was erzählt und danach kam natürlich das was immer kommen muss
irgendein super business enterprise dude meldet sich auf die frage hin ob es noch fragen gibt
und muss natürlich was fragen und er fragt eigentlich gar nichts sondern er fragt sowas
so eine einleitungsfrage um dann zehn minuten über sich selbst zu reden wo ich denke alter oder
fünf über sich selbst zu reden alter er findet sich schon geil ja also im konkreten fall war
das so der der der der kerl vom vorstand hat irgendwie in seiner rede erzählt wie keine
ahnung so sinngemäß wie wie ethisch ja unsere versicherungsgeschäfte sind und sowas wenn ich
sowas schon immer höre da muss ja immer eine runde kecken ja aber gut sowas wird sich ja da
gerne eingeredet dass sie so ethisch so auf dem richtigen fahrt sind oder was auch immer ist mir
egal die bezahlen pünktlich die können machen ethisch was sie wollen zumindest darauf hin hat
er sich dann gemeldet und hat gesagt ja und das findet er so toll und das ist auch der grund warum
er hier angefangen hat weil weil das so so auch der handel hier und solche sachen das ist alles
so nicht so schlimm wie bei irgendwelchen anderen privaten sachen und bla bla bla und da er macht
er schon seit seit fünf jahren hier sowas ist ja schon im business und das ist dann so toll und so
geil bei der firma dass der grund warum er sich hier beworben hat also alter das will doch keiner
hören man das war so typische typische wir müssen jetzt uns mal fünf minuten ins gespräch bringen
der vortrag von unserem also der der vortrag von dem von dem vorstands dud war wirklich interessant
und das war auch mal zur abwechslung einer wirklich gut reden konnte er und er hat ja
leuten gerne zu die gut reden können aber der andere typ der aus dem publikum sich dann ins
gespräch gebracht das war keine ahnung weil sich was mit was mit den leuten los ist ja und da gab
es noch mehr also gibt es eigentlich lust die legit auf solche veranstaltungen haben ja anscheinend
also ich muss sagen wer da auf jeden fall bock drauf hat sind diese event leute die sich solche
events ausdenken weil die waren richtig richtig jetzt man hat gemerkt die haben sich wirklich und
das muss man auch wirklich denke ich mal anerkennen die haben sich sehr viel mühe mit dem event gegeben
also auch wenn ich keinen bock auf so ein event habe ja und am liebsten das event nicht gehabt
hätte aber die haben sich mühe gegeben das hat man gemerkt also auch was sie vorbereitet haben an themen
das was sie erzählt haben haben sie auch gut durchdacht also in welcher reihenfolge sie das
hat es war wirklich gut gemacht und die haben auch ihren text gut geübt im vorfeld kannst du kannst
ich sagen die macht das bestimmt bock ich habe kein bock auf so veranstalten und ja wir hatten
dort halt auch sicherlich viele die was mit mit handel und und und traden und versicherungen und
sonst was zu tun haben da sind halt eher so bvl bis business laber leute die fanden es glaube ich
auch teilweise ganz geil ich hatte da keinen bock drauf ich ich hatte da keinen bock drauf ja und
wie gesagt da gab es dann immer so so sachen sie setzt euch jetzt ach ja und was dann auch noch
kam ist so nachdem sie erst erzählt haben nachdem sie erst erzählt haben so jetzt setzt euch mal
fünf minuten zusammen und überlegt euch was war das highlight der woche und danach kam und jetzt
nächste und jetzt jetzt nächster denkanstoß sie haben das ja nicht aufgabe genannt sondern jetzt
nächster denkanstoß jetzt setzt euch da mal mit 55 leuten zusammen und überlegt euch ich habe die
andere sache schon wieder vergessen was es war zumindest was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte ist
danach haben sie gesagt aber guckt darauf dass es nicht die fünf gleichen leute von eben sind sucht
euch andere leute raus das ist es war mir so anstrengend dann im endeffekt ist es dann so
gelaufen beim ersten mal beim erst bei der ersten fragerunde bin ich aufs klo gegangen hat mir die
antwort dazu überlegt bei der zweiten fragerunde bin ich draußen auf den balkon also da gab es
so eine terrasse auf die terrasse gegangen und habe damit ein paar anderen it leuten rum gestanden
und wir haben uns über die neue zip domain unterhalten also wir haben nichts von dieser
eigentlichen aufgabe gemacht und sie waren auch alle mit mir einer meinung das punkt zip als
domain richtig blöde idee gewesen ist da hatten wir irgendeinen it security typ dabei irgendein
typ fragt mich nicht der war gefühlt 150 oder so und hat die ganze zeit was von java auf solaris
erzählt der konnte bestimmt auch cobalt programmieren und und auch ein paar andere noch ein paar andere
leute als wir haben uns über die die neue zip domain und sowas unterhalten mit der aufgabe haben
nichts gemacht oder auch ja mein kollege hat richtig gemacht bevor die dritte runde anfing
diese dritte socializing runde hat er gesagt und das hat er auch wirklich äußerst geschickt gemacht
muss ich sagen hat er gesagt oh ich muss jetzt leider zum bahnhof und natürlich haben da manche
leute gesagt sowie muss jetzt zum bahnhof die veranstaltung ist noch gar nicht fertig hat er
gesagt ja sonst gibt es ärger ich bin heute nämlich schon seit 6 30 da und wenn du seit
6 30 da bist du darfst ja nur maximal du darfst ja nur maximum oder zumindest ich weiß nicht was
er denen erzählt hat er hat ihnen erzählt dass er sonst über seine zehn stunden arbeitszeit
kommt das gibt sonst ärger und das aber schade dass du weg musst ja ich hoffe dir hat es trotzdem
gefallen oder hat er sich bei der vor der dritten aufgabe zum vom acker gemacht zum bahnhof richtig
so hätte ich es auch machen sollen
ich glaube ja nicht dass das stimmte
aber das war das war richtig ja richtig pfeil fern ist das gewesen von ihm aber ich weiß nicht
wie viele leute es gibt die bock auf solche veranstaltungen haben aber es gibt auf jeden
fall welche die bock auf so socialize veranstaltungen haben ich nicht und das wisst ihr ja auch
was bei unserer firma also kurz schwarz schreibt bei unserer firma veranstaltungen sollten sich
alle azubis einer bestimmten formation aufstellen damit einer mit einer drohne ein foto von oben
machen kann da bin ich auch einfach beste beste idee klo ist immer gut und wisst ihr was das
gute ist auf ich muss mal aufs klo da kann niemand was dagegen sagen
nicht schäler das sind nicht die uns dass du musst ein ad ein ad musst du machen aber
dann lösche ich deine chat nachricht wenn es hier schreibst aber nein es mussten du
musst ein ad machen kein und muss hat der tp davor schreiben mit utf mit unicode zeichen
für die slashes ja dass das gute ist also ich muss jetzt aufs klo ist immer eine ausrede
da kann auch keiner was dagegen sagen wenn einer sagt ja doch dauert auch nur zehn minuten
dann ist das foto aber es drückt aber und was was für das sagt niemand was da kann
keiner was dagegen sagen klo ist immer beste beste ausrede bei sowas
ja wenn sie oft wenn sie auf einen warten können da hast du halt pech
jetzt bitte in fünfer gruppen zusammensetzen da nehmt ihr euch ein plakat und macht eine
präsentation über das thema euer chat also meine aufgabe an euch setzt euch in fünfer
gruppen zusammen und nehmt euch ein plakat und macht eine präsentation über thema nein
wir machen das doch besser jetzt setzt euch jetzt bitte in fünfer gruppen zusammen nehmt
euch ein plakat und überlegt euch ein thema für eure präsentation was ihr gerne machen wollt
und in 15 und dann und dann wir machen es doch besser leute und ihr wählt dann bitte
einen sprecher für die gruppe der in der in der um 20 uhr der um 21 uhr 15 an euer
präsentationsthema vorstellt mit einer folie maximal zwei drei sätze und fünf minuten zeit
let's go dass das wäre so typisches business enterprise socialize consulting geschiss genau
auf solche sachen habe ich keinen bock
leute bei einer versicherung bank arbeiten auch nur wegen der kohle da gibt es doch nichts
moralisches dran ja sehe ich ähnlich also ich bin da auch nur wegen dem geld also das stimmt
nicht ich bin da nicht nur wegen dem geld ich bin wegen dem geld da ich bin wegen der guten
homeoffice regelung da ich bin auch mittlerweile muss ich sagen da weil ich die leute wirklich nett
finde und also in meinem team und auch den umgang intern teamübergreifend und im team auch aber
das handling mit den leuten und dass wir endlich auch mal eine fähige personalabteilung haben und
sowas ich finde die firma bis jetzt wirklich nice allerdings so dieses man macht da so super
ethische geschichten und sowas das muss man sich in keiner versicherung oder bank irgendwie einreden
das machen sie gerne bei manchen und das habe ich auch schon aus erster hand erlebt bei manchen
arte das schon in jahr sagen wir so sektenartige rituale aus das habe ich jetzt dort wo ich jetzt
aktuell bin zumindest noch nicht mitgekriegt aber habe ich schon erlebt also naja ich bin ich meine
technik ist ja schon ja gut es gibt leute die finden das sogar toll die kommt mal ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen es gibt leute wenn du die fragst und die meinen das ernst die meinen das
wirklich ernst das muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen wenn du die fragst ja in welcher
in welcher richtung möchtest du denn arbeiten dann sagen die leute ich möchte gerne was mit
menschen machen das ja auch jetzt was mit menschen machen es ist ungefähr genauso genauso aussage
kräftig wie ich mache was mit computer aber ich frage mich immer was ein zu so einer aussage
treibt nein ich will nix mit menschen machen menschen gehen mir zu 99 prozent auf den sack
moin patrick arbeite noch bei der windows only für mich war nie bei der windows only firma ich
habe den windows notebook ja das habe ich immer noch und ich habe aber mittlerweile
eine linux vm auf der ich rote rechte habe wo ich fast überall hinkomme und und ich eigentlich
nichts anderes mache auf meinem windows notebook wie wischel studio code im fullscreen auf dann
ein terminal im fullscreen auf und auf die linux vm connecten
das ist das ist kein kindergarten in dem sind das ist normal das ist das ist also das was ich
euch erzählt habe das ist im business enterprise umfeld vollkommen normal dass es solche veranstaltungen
gibt es gibt immer welche die meinen das ist das finden sie geil und es gibt auch kaum firmen die
nicht ab und zu mal irgendwelche team building workshops oder so ein blödsinn machen ich meine
ich drücke mich ja vor den meisten schon immer wenn das wenn das freiwillige wenn das freiwillige
veranstaltungen sind dann gehe ich da nicht hin das liegt wie gesagt ich habe es schon oft gesagt
das liegt bei mir auch gar nicht daran dass ich dass ich die leute irgendwie nicht nicht ab kann
oder so die meisten leute kenne ich nicht die sind mir eigentlich ziemlich egal und ich will
einfach nach der arbeit was anderes machen als weiter mit der arbeit was zu tun haben ja also
die meisten leute sind mir egal ein paar mag ich hauptsächlich die die ich besser kenne aus aus dem
team beziehungsweise mit dem man besser öfters zusammenarbeit viele mag ich auch nicht aber daran
liegt es gar nicht ich habe bloß einfach keinen bock abends noch irgendwas da dazu machen und
soll also so alle alle freiwilligen veranstaltungen haben sie ja gestern auch wieder erzählt wo bald
startet unser großes sommerfest wir hoffen sie dort alle begrüßen zu können ich werde nicht auf
das sommerfest gehen das weiß ich jetzt schon ich gehe nicht auf das sommerfest ich will meine
ruhe haben ich will videos machen ich will streamen ich will mit euch ein bisschen schwätzen ich will
am haus rum bauen und sei es nur auf der terrasse sitzen und mit meiner katz auf der terrasse sitzen
was auch immer ich habe keinen bock bis 23 sommerfest zu machen so zumindest was wollte
ich jetzt eigentlich sagen also wie gesagt bei bei irgendwelchen freiwilligen veranstaltungen
bin ich immer raus sofort das wissen also beim alten arbeitgeber wussten dass die leute auch
schon die müssen mich da gar nicht muss da gar nicht mit mir rechnen beim neuen muss ich mal
gucken wie ich das den leuten noch noch beibringen dass ich keinen bock auf auf
es ist nämlich so wenn die leute eigentlich kennen ja dann dann können die einen nicht so
richtig einschätzen und dann denken glaube ich viele instinktiv das liegt an ihnen dass man mit
ihnen nichts zu tun haben will oder so ja kann auch sein aber ist meistens gar nicht so sehr
der fall ich will einfach nach der arbeit was anderes machen als mit leuten von der arbeit
was zu tun haben es sei denn also die einzigen die einzigen sachen die ich mitgemacht habe auf
der alten arbeit und die ich auch theoretisch auf der neuen arbeit mitmachen würde sind so
sachen wie hier lasst uns mal lasst uns mal hier mit dem gesamten linux team mal was futtern gehen
oder so ja das ist das ist das sind dann aber auch leute mit denen habe ich tagtäglich zu tun mit
denen verstehe ich mich zum größten teil ganz gut oder zumindest mit sagen wir so 45 leuten
verstehe ich mich ganz gut das reicht dann zu denen kann man sich auch hinhocken ja und es
gibt was zu essen das ist okay aber sommerfest oder ist immer so eine riesen veranstaltung mit
1000 leuten dabei und das habe ich echt da habe ich keinen bock drauf er kennt mich bei so was
ja also wie gesagt wenn es keine pflicht ist gehe ich da in der regel auch nicht hin
und wenn es was offizielles ist sei es jetzt irgendwelche team building work maßnahmen oder
team building workshop maßnahmen oder so was dann ist es ja auch arbeitszeit also
alles was offiziell ist muss arbeitszeit sein und dann gehe ich da auch hin
also können mich ruhig wenn die zwei tage team building workshop oder so was oder oder keine
ahnung eine woche team building maßnahmen machen wollen und das alles arbeitszeit ist soll mir
recht sein
also der einzige fall bisher wo mich das interessiert hat war und das habe ich euch
erzählt das war noch als ich azubi war beim provider meine eine mit auszubilde die die
bei der weihnachtsfeier gefragt hat ob ich sie heimbringen kann wo wo ich verkackt habe das
habe ich euch ja schon das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt ansonsten hat mich das nicht
großartig interessiert du weißt ja never fuck the company das hat mich nicht interessiert und
ich glaube mittlerweile mit fast überlegt euch das mal müsst ihr euch mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen mit fast 40 ich werde 39 dieses jahr hat sich das auch alles ein bisschen erledigt
dragula schreibt unsere firma spinnt leider komplett gerade management macht nur fehlentscheidung
kaum it wissen nur projektmanagement und die personalabteilung ist auch schwierig es macht
kaum spaß weil einem nur steine in den weg gelegen das hört sich nach typischen business
enterprise kram an sicherlich auch größere firma wobei das in kleineren auch passiert
das hört sich nach typischen business enterprise kram an ich kann euch übrigens was witziges
erzählen ich habe jetzt ein bisschen in den letzten tage über mit leuten von meinem alten
ehemaligen arbeitgeber gesprochen und da geht es richtig den berg ab gerade also ganz viele
leute rennen weg also haben jetzt noch viel mehr leute gekündigt auch welche die ich kenne viele
leute gehen noch weg sie versuchen irgendwie die lücken an leuten die entstanden sind out zu
sorcen an dienstleister und dazu finden sie entweder keine dienstleister dienstleister
nur die hälfte von dem machen was die leute jetzt machen da geht es gerade so steil den
berg ab bei meinem alten arbeitgeber dass mich in irgendeiner gewissen art und weise für den also
nicht für die leute die noch verblieben sind die ich kenne aber für den arbeitgeber nachdem man
hat es ja meilenweit kommen sehen ja hat schon seinen grund warum ich da abgehauen bin auch
freut es mich ja schon so ein bisschen schadensfroh bin ich da ja schon der osten meldet sich zurück
auch von dem habe ich schon eine weile nichts mehr gehört ich meine wir schreiben unregelmäßig ab und
zu in discord ja aber von dem habe ich tatsächlich schon eine ganze weile nichts mehr gehört das
geben geben tut sind fabian noch ja aber was der aktuell macht weiß ich nicht das letzte was ich
von ihm gehört habe ist dass er er sich diablo 4 für die xbox kaufen will oder so was und ab und
zu ab und zu mal ab und zu wieder streamen wollte allerdings wir kennen ihn ja der macht das genauso
wenig wie ich ja heute vor dem kapital das ist übrigens ihr müsst gar nicht probieren dass es
nicht meint dass nicht der woblos account das ist extra ein fake account den ich mir angelegt habe
für hier dass ich mich einloggen kann dass der chat noch funktioniert er hat nicht hat nicht
mehr gestreamt in letzter zeit ist er immer noch am mobile game kreiden ja so wie ich den kenne
schon ja der frazier also geben tut sie noch ja schäler du besonders ich meine es hat schon
seinen grund dass du deinen fünften discord account hast weil immer vorher gebannt wurdest
überall oder ist es der fünfte twitch account ich weiß es gar nicht mehr ich
lehne der fünfte discord account oder ja kann ich vor 1 level ist ja aber auch abartig
wichtig studio code funktioniert tatsächlich der trick ist man muss
wichtig studio code erst mal fünf minuten offen lassen dann geht es halbwegs ich meine ich habe
ein relativ fettes notebook irgendwie weiß ich sechs kerne 32 gramm also das ist nicht schlecht
das teil aber ja wenn man halt 32 security viren scanner im hintergrund hat dann muss man sich
wundern wenn alles lahm ist übrigens da gibt's cringe cringe sache bei dieser bei
dieser einführungsveranstaltung oder bei diesem onboarding veranstaltung wo ich letztens gewesen
bin da sollten alle leute also von diesem socializing networking event wo ich euch
gerade erzählt habe da sollten die leute im vorfeld sich alle auf so eine pin wand schreiben
auf so eine virtuelle pin wand somit mit foto und mit fun facts und was ist meine superkraft
und sowas stand da drauf und also ich habe drauf geschrieben ich habe drauf geschrieben
meine superkraft ist auf die idee hat mich der chat gebracht ohne euch wäre ich gar nicht auf
die idee gekommen das habe ich gemacht ich habe drauf geschrieben ich habe drauf geschrieben
bei uns art by the way und bei fun fact habe ich da habe ich reingeschrieben dass ich das
dass ich mit meinem anderen kolleg da dass wir uns schon kennen was hätte ich ohne den chat geschrieben
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht deswegen habe ich euch das letzte mal auch gefragt
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich irgendwas wahrscheinlich hätte ich geschrieben auf
meinem klo läuft linux was er so streng genommen gar nicht stimmt nee weiß ich nicht ich keine
ahnung was ich da drauf geschrieben hat aber gut dass ihr mich auf die idee gebracht habt
ich habe ich drauf geschrieben aber es haben andere leute deutlich cringiere sachen drauf
geschrieben und manche leute haben auch sachen drauf geschrieben die hätte ich so nicht drauf
geschrieben bei einer business veranstaltung einer hat drauf geschrieben fun fact noch nie gekotzt
von alkohol aber da dachte ich mir so okay ist das angemessen für eine business veranstaltung
so blöden spruch da drauf zu schreiben
fun fact 20 zentimeter
er hätte ja wenigstens elotrix hätte er drauf schreiben können was hat er früher in den
videos immer erzählt 20 zentimeter deutscher stahl da hätte man wenigstens erkennen können
wobei man weiß ja mittlerweile sogar wie raus schaut ich vergaß man weiß es ja sogar mittlerweile
der kommt der typ kommt sicher aus der medienbräuer das kann durchaus sein ich
habe nicht geguckt woher kommt keine ahnung
da war ich ja auch kein geheimnis drum
ja sage ich gar nichts dagegen solange es leute sind die man sich aussuchen kann und wo beide
seiten bock drauf haben überhaupt kein problem ich gehe immer noch regelmäßig mittagessen mit
paar kollegen von früher und auch mit welchen von früher wo ich halt vor zwei monaten noch war
überhaupt kein ding solange man sich das aussuchen kann habe ich da keine schmerzen mit ich schreibe
regelmäßig mit leuten auch über twitter pnz über discord über sonst was von von den alten jobs aber
das sind ja leute mit denen kann ich mir das aussuchen ich nein ich du musst dich doch nicht
krank schreiben lassen für sommerfest und die weihnachtsfeier du kriegst einfach nicht hin das
ist nicht arbeitszeit das ist eine freiwillige veranstaltung da können kann keiner was also
können schon was sagen aber pech meine arbeit also kellner schreibt meine arbeit hatte letztens
communities auf so einer intern social plattform aufgemacht wie gaming sport für mitarbeiter
außerhalb der was sagen ok das klingt jetzt vielleicht blöd ja das klingt jetzt vielleicht
blöd aber ich finde es gut sowas nicht dass ich jetzt für mich persönlich da große versuchung
verspüren würde da unbedingt nach der arbeit noch hinzugehen aber ich weiß ja auch dass nicht alle
leute so sind wie ich also insofern finde ich das gut dass es so was gibt gerade guckt mal
überlegt euch mal viele leute sitzen den ganzen tag am schreibtisch und fahren heim und und man
und die motivation für viele mal sich ein bisschen zu bewegen ist deutlich höher wenn andere dabei
sind als wenn sie alleine vor sich hin hocken also zu sagen hey man muss ja nicht ins fitnessstudio
nebendran sein ja reicht ja schon zu sagen hey kommen wir gehen wir gehen jetzt hier noch eine
stunde durch die stadt oder sowas das ist für viele leute besser wenn da wenn die einfach mit
mehreren machen weil das weil sie sich alleine da halt nicht dazu aufraffen können also das finde
ich gut dass sowas gibt es kann übrigens sein dass ich demnächst sogar bei sowas mitmachen
werde allerdings nicht direkt bei sowas sondern ich habe gelesen es gibt bei uns irgendwie so
ein innovationsforum oder irgendwie so hieß das dazu kann man sich dazu kann man sich anmelden und
das geht dann wohl auch teilweise von der arbeitszeit ab und da habe mein kollege also
mein ex ex und wieder kollege und ich haben uns da überlegt ob wir uns nicht da zusammen bei für
anmelden sollen da können wir nämlich zusammen ein bisschen an was arbeiten weil wir sind ja nicht
im gleichen team und es geht von der arbeitszeit ab also beziehungsweise auch bezahlt da machen
wir vielleicht demnächst mit wobei das halt keine social plattform für außerhalb der arbeit ist und
sowas kommt prinzipiell überall gut an wenn man bei sowas mitmacht also insofern ist das für uns
eigentlich doppelt nice wir können mal zusammen wieder was machen auch auf der arbeit und man hat
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen was von wie läuft es mit dem abnehmen thema nicht so wirklich
also ich hatte letztens 91,8 oder so glaube ich das hatte ich es gibt eigentlich keine neuen rekorde
zu vermelden aber das macht auch nix ich war über 90 unter 90 in dem jahr hoffe ich hoffe ich schon
noch drauf dass ich das hinkriege aber es macht ja im prinzip auch nix ich meine es ist immerhin
von 108,5 auf 91,5 runter das sind auch 17 kilo und 17 kilo ich sage euch man merkt wirklich ich
habe letztens bin ich heimgelaufen vom hauptbahnhof aus so eine runde am
einlang so ungefähr eineinhalb stunden oder so würde ich sagen hat es gedauert die runde da bin
ich gelaufen mit einem rucksack auf dem rücken war drin notebook thermoskanne eine hose
bisschen bisschen geld schlüssel hände so zeug was man im rucksack hat ja und der rucksack hat
glaube ich nur ich will jetzt nichts falsches sagen ich glaube irgendwie um die sechs kilo
gewogen mit allem drinnen und der ging mir schon extrem auf den keks wenn ich jetzt überlege ich
ich hatte quasi das gewicht von diesem rucksack dreimal so viel über meinen
gesamten körper so verteilt 17 kilo sind schon ordentlich also vom gewicht her ja und das merkt
man auch also ich bin ich bin ich war letztens ein bisschen spät und ich bin von das kann ich
euch in frankfurt nicht nicht nicht erzählen weil da wisst ihr da wisst ihr wo ich wo ich
arbeite ich bin so ungefähr knapp unter dem kilometer könnte man sagen was du was dürften
das sein 800 900 meter bin ich bin ich zum hauptbahnhof gerannt und ich glaube so eine
strecke bin ich jahrelang schon nicht mehr gerannt weil ich nie so strecken rennen muss
und ich weiß was ich bin mir relativ sicher hätte ich noch 108,5 gewogen hätte ich es im
leben nicht auf die reihe gebracht von dort bis quasi zum eingang vom hauptbahnhof zu rennen und
danach war ich auch gar nicht super fertig das ging eigentlich also 17 kilo weniger merkt man
schon ziemlich von der taunusanlage zum hauptbahnhof ja das kommt ungefähr hin
auch von der entfernung ja
ja genau maps google ja taunusanlage
von hier zum
der hauptbahnhof muss doch hier unten irgendwo sein ach da ist er ja ja so
ungefähr ungefähr ungefähr so von der strecke und ich war danach nicht komplett
im arsch also insofern hat sich das hat sich tatsächlich gelohnt mit dem abnehmen
ja das ist ja okay was aber nicht zwangsläufig heißt dass man das außerhalb der arbeitszeit
machen muss also man hat durchaus auch schon chancen während der arbeitszeit zu zeigen dass
man plan hat und sich irgendwie den namen zu machen das muss man nicht beim bier nach der
arbeit machen also wenn man es nicht wenn man es nicht schafft mit techniker mit technik mit
technischer kompetenz und sagen wir mal vielleicht auch drüber reden weiter zu kommen dass es nur
noch abends geht dann ist auch irgendwas verkehrt aber du hast natürlich recht das wichtigste auf
der arbeit ist nicht so sehr technisch gute sachen zu machen das wichtigste unterm strich ist technisch
ganz sinnvolle sachen zu machen und im nachhinein aber darüber zu reden dass man technisch tolle
sachen gemacht hat wenn man es mal so ausdrücken kann also wenn man was macht sollte es gut
durchdacht sein aber dann darf man durchaus auch mal eine ganze weile drüber drüber philosophieren
wie toll das war was man gemacht hat so ist das ein bisschen enterprise umfeld leider als die
leute die wirklich den ganzen tag von morgens bis abends schaffen und ganz tolle sachen machen die
sind weniger bekannt beim management als leute die ganz gut durchsacht durchdachte dinger machen
ja ich meine komplett in die hose gehen dürfen deine dinger auch was du machst auch nicht die
ganze zeit die ganz gut durchdachte sachen machen und halt danach einen großen wind drum machen die
sind deutlich bekannter als welche die einfach nur durchschaffen und zwar super super dinger
implementieren und erledigen aber von denen man nie hört das ist halt leider doof aber es ist
leider so auch wenn es doof ist bestes beispiel ist letztes beispiel bei mir auf der alten arbeit
ja wir hatten eine war russe an der stelle mal mal erwähnt also das deutsch war auch nicht seine
muttersprache was noch dazu beigetragen hat der hat von morgens bis abends der hat glaube ich mit
abstand die meisten tickets bearbeitet von allen du hast geguckt auch jedes ticket ist wer hat
der hat die arbeit für drei leute geschafft aber meint ihr von dem hat irgendwie einer großartig
was gehört außerhalb von unserem team beziehungsweise von unseren 23 teams in der
ecke nie die hatten keine ahnung wirklich dass es den gibt so und um ein gegenbeispiel zu zu
bringen der kolleg mit dem ich jetzt auch die arbeit gewechselt habe mit dem zusammen habe
ich mich ab und zu bei man für manche sachen freiwillig gemeldet das waren immer dinger zum
größten teil zumindest die nicht super kompliziert waren und die auch nicht irgendwie jetzt monate
lange harten einsatz gefordert haben ja wir haben uns wir haben uns freiwillig gemeldet zum beispiel
was man belegen wozu haben wir uns freiwillig gemeldet genau wir haben uns freiwillig dazu
gemeldet zum beispiel bei so einem innovations workshop mitzumachen oder am ende verschiedene
ideen für neue für neue mobile apps vorgestellt wurden und sowas wir haben uns wir haben uns
freiwillig dazu gemeldet man könnte doch mal unser unser dokumentationssystem überarbeiten
und sowas jetzt alles nicht so super hartes technisches zeug ja wir haben wir haben uns dazu
was überlegt haben eine gute präsentation drüber gehalten das ist tatsächlich das a und o haben uns
dahingestellt zu zweit haben eine viertelstunde präsentation gehalten und danach waren alle
begeistert und die kannten uns alle das ist halt der unterschied der eine hat wirklich sehr viel
gemacht und er hat sicherlich unterm strich deutlich mehr weggeschafft als als wir beiden
zusammenfasst schon aber wir haben uns halt die prestigeträchtigen themen rausgepickt und die
dann im großen stil halt was zu gesagt das war unterm strich für man kennt die leute und man
kommt voran besser als das andere wer jetzt dem unternehmen mehr bringt ja da kann man sich drüber
streiten also ich würde sagen mein russischer kollege der die tickets abgearbeitet hat bringt
mehr unterm strich aber das ist halt nicht das gefühl was das management hat das heißt die
hören halt manchmal gerne auch einfach ein bisschen bla bla die die wollen die wollen
gerne einfach ein bisschen bla bla hören und wenn sie das hören wollen dann kriegen sie das auch
danielo dankeschön für den zap
was habe ich für ein notebook irgendwas von ap